the car is crucial to the school run for
rosie and mum amy
but filling up is a nasty surprise one
we're going to have to all get used to
it made me feel a bit sick just watching
it go up and up and up i couldn't
believe that it was that much looking at
where we're spending every week you know
not going on foreign holidays you know
where's our money going i feel like we'd
already been doing quite a good job of
tightening our belts for unleaded petrol
and diesel the 100 pound tank is now the
norm motoring groups want an immediate
10p cut to the taxes that make up 45
percent of pump prices the prime
minister suggested retailers still
haven't passed on a five p cut made in
march what i want to see is
those cuts in taxation not just
swallowed up in one gulp without
touching the gullet
of the uh of the the fuel companies i
want to see i want to see those uh those
those cuts having an impact on the pumps
but with oil prices still high up almost
57 this year that cut has long since
been negated by rising wholesale prices
not least because sanctions against
russia a major supplier of diesel have
cut supply
retailers insist they're not
profiteering our members don't want to
sell at these prices but they can't sell
at a loss um i mean many of our members
know their customers personally they
come in on a regular basis and they know
the pressures that uh you know this puts
on household budgets but unfortunately
we buy on a wholesale basis and we have
to have to make money out of it
petrol and diesel are at record levels
but it is not unusual as here to find
prices at the pump more than 10 p higher
than that and you don't have to be a
driver to be affected these prices are
nearly 40 percent higher than a year ago
and fuel is so fundamental to the
economy they're contributing nearly one
percent to general inflation everyone is
going to pay a price
charities like brent community transport
are feeling the squeeze they provide
transport for the elderly the infirm and
youth groups oh wow
um it makes um the one down the road
that looks cheap
this has already won 95
chairman moses is counting the cost of
filling each of his 22 vehicles
137 pounds
12 months ago and i'm really stretching
it 12 months it could even be less i was
filling up for nearly 80.
so that's a huge
and there's no extra money coming in so
it has to come from our reserves how
long we can sustain that i really don't
know
we do know prices won't be going into
reverse anytime soon paul kelso sky news